the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so we're ready to begin the fifth
lecture I'm glad to be back thank you
for for entertaining my colleague Haynes
Miller so today we're going to continue
where he started namely what he talked
about was the chain rule which is
probably the most powerful technique for
extending the kinds of functions that
you can differentiate now we're going to
use the chain rule in some rather clever
algebraic ways today so the topic for
today is what's known as implicit
differentiation so implicit
differentiation is a technique that
allows you to differentiate a lot of
functions you didn't even know how to
find before and it's a technique let's
wait for a few people to sit down here
physics huh okay well more physics
we'll take a break you can get those
after class all right so we're talking
about implicit differentiation and I'm
going to illustrate it by several
examples so this is one of the most
important and basic formulas that we've
already learned part way namely the
derivative of X to a power is a times X
to the a minus 1 now what we've done so
far what we've got so far is the
exponents 0 plus or minus 1 plus or
minus 2 etc you did the integer positive
integer powers on in the first lecture
and then yesterday professor Miller told
you about the negative powers so what
we're going to do right now today is
we're going to consider the exponents
which are rational numbers ratios of
integers so a is M over N m and and our
integers all right so that's our goal
for right now and we're going to use
this method of implicit differentiation
in particular it's important to realize
that this covers the case M equals 1 and
those are the nth roots so when we take
the 1 over N power we're going to cover
that right now along with many other
examples ok
so this is our first example so how do
we get started well we just write down a
formula for the function the function is
y is equal to X to the power M over N
that's what we're trying to deal with
and now there's really only two steps
the first step is to take this to the
this equation to the nth power so write
it as Y to the N is equal to X to the M
all right so that's just the same
equation rewritten and now what we're
going to do
is we're going to differentiate so we're
going to apply dy/dx to the equation now
why is it that we can apply it to the
second equation not the first equation
so maybe I should call these equations 1
in equation 2
the point is that we can apply it to
equation 2 now the reason is that we
don't know how to differentiate X to the
M over N that's something we just don't
know yet
but we do know how to differentiate
integer powers those are the things that
we took care of before so now we're in
shape to be able to do the
differentiation so I'm going to write it
out explicitly over here without
carrying it out just yet that's d by DX
of Y to the N is equal to d by DX of X
to the M power and now you see this
expression here requires us to do
something we couldn't do before
yesterday namely this Y is a function of
X so we have to apply the chain rule
here
so this is the same as this is by the
chain rule now D by dy of Y to the N
times dy/dx and then on the right hand
side we can just carry it out we know
the formula it's M X to the M minus 1
all right so this is our our scheme and
now you'll see in a minute why we win
with this so first of all there are two
factors here one of them is unknown in
fact it's what we're looking for but the
other one is going to be a known
quantity because we know how to
differentiate Y to the n with respect to
Y that's the same formula although the
letter has been changed and so this is
the same as I'll write it underneath
here and Y to the N minus 1 dy/dx is
equal to M next
- one okay now comes if you like the the
non-calculus part of the problem
remember the non calculus part of the
problem is always the Messier part of
the problem so we want to figure out
this formula this formula the answer
over here which was which maybe I'll put
in a box now has this expressed much
more simply only in terms of X and what
we have to do now is to solve for dy/dx
using algebra and then solve in all the
way in terms of X so first of all we
solve for dy/dx so I do that by dividing
the factor on the left hand side so I
get here M X to the M minus 1 divided by
n y to the N minus 1 and now I'm going
to plug in so I'll write this is M over
N this is X to the M minus 1 and now
over here I'm going to put in for Y X to
the M over N times n minus 1 all right
so now we're almost done but
unfortunately we have this mess of
exponents that we have to work out I'm
going to write it one more time so I
already recognize the fact or a out
front that's not going to be a problem
for me and that's what I'm aiming for
here but now I have to encode all of
these powers so let's just write it out
it's M minus 1 and then it's minus the
quantity n minus 1 times M over N all
right so that's the law of exponents
applied to this ratio here and then
we'll do the arithmetic maybe just over
here in the next board so we have here M
minus 1 minus n minus 1 M over N is
equal to M minus 1 and if I multiply n
by this I get minus M and at the second
factor
- - that's a plus and it's that's plus M
over N so all together the two M's
cancel and I have here minus one plus M
over N and lo and behold that's the same
thing as a minus one just what we wanted
all right so this equals a X to the a
minus one again just a bunch of
arithmetic from this point forward from
this substitution on it's just the
arithmetic of exponents alright so we've
done our first example here and I guess
I want to give you a couple more
examples so let's just continue the next
example
I'll keep it relatively simple so we
have example two which is going to be
the function x squared plus y squared is
equal to 1 well that's not really a
function this again is a way of defining
Y as a function of X implicitly
there's the idea that I could solve for
y if I wanted to and indeed let's do
that so if you solve for y here what
happens is you get Y squared is equal to
1 minus x squared and Y is equal to plus
or minus square root of 1 minus x
squared so this if you like is the
implicit definition and here is the
explicit function y is a function of X
and now just for my own convenience I'm
just going to take the positive branch
right this is the function let's just
draw it right above here right it's
really a circle in disguise and I'm just
going to take the top part of the circle
so we'll take that that top hump here
all right so that means I'm erasing this
minus sign I'm just taking the positive
branch just for my convenience I could
do it just as well with the negative
branch all right so now I've taken the
solution and I can differentiate this so
rather than using this dy by DX notation
over here I'm going to switch notations
on over here because it's less writing
and I'm going to write Y Prime and
change notations okay so I want to take
the derivative of this well this is a
somewhat complicated function here it's
the square root of 1 minus x squared and
the right way always to look at
functions like this is to rewrite them
using the fractional power notation all
right that's the first step in computing
a derivative of a square root and then
the second step here is what somebody
want to tell me what chain rule yeah
that's good chain rule that's it so we
have two things we hit start with one
and then we do something else to it so
whenever we do two things to something
we need to apply the chain rule so 1
minus x squared square root all right so
so how do we do that well the first
factor I claim is the derivative of this
thing so this is 1/2
blaah to the minus 1/2 so I'm doing this
by the sort of advanced method now
because we've already graduated you
already did the chain rule last time so
what does this mean this is an
abbreviation for the derivative with
respect to blah blah to the 1/2 whatever
it is right so that's the first factor
that we're going to use rather than
actually write out a variable for it and
and pass through as I did previously
with this
an X variable here I'm just going to
skip that step and I'm going to let you
imagine it as being a placeholder for
that variable so this variable is now
parentheses and then I have to multiply
that by the rate of change of what's
inside with respect to X and that is
going to be minus 2x
all right the derivative of 1 minus x
squared is is minus 2x and now again
we're glomming everything together here
we couldn't have done this example two
before example one because we needed to
know that the power rule worked not just
for a integer but also for a equals 1/2
we're using the case a equals 1/2 right
here it's 1/2 times and this minus 1/2
here is a minus 1 right so this is the
case a equals 1/2 a minus 1 happens to
be minus 1/2 okay so I'm putting all
those things together and you know
within a week you have to be doing this
very automatically so we're going to do
it at this speed now you want to do it
even faster ultimately yes the question
is could I have done it implicitly
without the square roots and the answer
is yes that's what I'm about to do okay
so this is an illustration of what's
called the explicit solution so this guy
is what's called explicit and I want to
contrast it with the method that we're
going to now use today so it involves a
lot of complications that involves the
chain rule and as we'll see it it can
get Messier and Messier and then there's
the implicit method which I claim is
easier alright so let's see what happens
if you do it implicitly the implicit
method involves instead of writing the
function in this relatively complicated
with with a square root it involves
leaving it alone don't do anything to it
in this previous case
we were left with something which was
complicated say X to the 1/3 or X to the
one half of something complicated we had
to simplify it we used we had an
equation one which was more complicated
we simplified it and then differentiated
it and so that was the simpler case well
here the simplest thing for us the
simplest equation for us to
differentiate is the one we started with
because squares are the practically the
easiest things after first powers or
maybe zeroth powers to differentiate so
we're leaving it alone this is the
simplest possible form for it and now
we're going to differentiate so what
happens we get so again what's the
method let me remind you you're applying
D by DX to the equation so you have to
differentiate the left side of the
equation and differentiate the right
side of the equation so it's this and
what you get is 2x plus 2y y prime is
equal to what 0 derivative of 1 is 0 all
right so this is the chain rule again I
did it a different way I'm trying to get
you used to many different notations at
once here well really just to just the
prime notation and the dy/dx notation
and this is what I get all right so now
all I have to do is solve for y prime so
that Y prime if I put the 2x on the
other side is minus 2x and then divided
by 2y which is minus x over Y all right
so let's compare our solutions apologize
I'm going to have to erase something too
to do that so let's compare our two
solutions I'm going to put this
underneath and simplify so what was our
solution over here it was 1/2 1 minus x
squared to the minus 1/2 times minus 2x
that was what what we got over here
and that is the same thing if I cancel
the twos and I change it back to looking
like a square root that's the same thing
as minus X divided by square root of 1
minus x squared all right so this is the
formula for the derivative when I do it
the explicit way and I'll just compare
them these two expressions here and and
notice that they are the same all right
they're the same because Y is equal to
square root of 1 minus x squared yeah
question
bottom the question is why did the
implicit method not give the bottom half
of the circle very good question the
answer to that is that it did I just
didn't mention it wait wait I'll explain
so suppose I had stuck in a minus sign
here okay I would have gotten this with
a difference so with an extra minus sign
but then when I compared it to what was
over there I would have had to have
another different minus sign over here
so actually both places would get an
extra minus sign and they would still
coincide so actually the implicit method
is a little better it doesn't even
notice the difference between the
branches it does the job both on both
the top and the bottom half another way
of saying that is that you're
calculating the slopes here so let's
look at this picture here's a slope
let's just take a look at a positive
value of X and just check the signs to
see what's happening if you take a
positive value of x over here X is
positive this denominator is positive
the slope is negative you can see that
it's tilting down all right so it's okay
now on the bottom side it's going to be
tilting up and similarly what's
happening up here is that both x and y
are positive and this.x and this.y are
positive and the slope is negative on
the other hand on the bottom side X is
still positive but Y is negative and
it's tilting up because the the
denominator is negative
is positive in this minus sign is it a
positive slope so it matches perfectly
in every category so this that this is a
complicated however and it's easier just
to keep track of one branch at a time
even in advanced math okay so we only do
it one branch at a time other questions
okay so now I want to give you a
slightly more complicated example here
and indeed some of the so here's here's
a little more complicated example it's
not going to be the most complicated
example but you know will be a little
bit tricky okay so so this example I'm
going to I'm going to give you a fourth
order equation so Y to the fourth plus
XY squared minus two is equal to zero
right now it just so happens that
there's a trick to solving this equation
so actually you can all you can do both
the explicit method and the non explicit
method okay so the explicit method would
say okay well I want to solve for this
so I'm going to use the quadratic
formula but on on y squared this is
quadratic in y squared because there's a
fourth power and a second power and the
first in the in the third powers are
missing so this is y squared is equal to
minus X plus or minus the square root of
x squared - -4 x minus two divided by
two okay
so this X is the B this minus two is the
C and a is equal to one in the quadratic
formula
and so the formula for y is plus or
minus the square root of minus X plus or
minus the square root of x squared plus
eight divided by two
all right so now you can see this
problem of branches this happens
actually in a lot of cases coming up in
an elaborate way you have two choices
for the sign here you have two choices
for the sign here conceivably there as
many as four roots to this equation
because it's a fourth degree equation
it's quite a mess you should have to
check each branch separately and this is
really is that level of complexity and
in general it's very difficult to figure
out the the formulas for quartic
equations but fortunately we're never
going to use them that is we're never
going to need those formulas so the
implicit method is far easier so the
implicit method just says okay I'll
leave the equation in its simplest form
and now differentiate so when I
differentiate I get 4y cubed Y prime
plus now here I have to apply the
product rule so I differentiate the X
and the y squared separately first I
differentiate with respect to X so I get
Y squared then I differentiate with
respect to the other factor the Y
squared factor and I get x times 2y y
prime and then the 0 gives me 0 so minus
0 0 alright so there's the implicit
differentiation step and now I just want
to solve for y Prime so I'm going to
factor out for y cubed plus 2xy that's
the factor on Y prime and I'm going to
put the Y squared on the other side
minus y squared over here
and so the formula for y prime is minus
y squared divided by 4 y cubed plus 2xy
so that's the the formula for the for
the solution for the slope do you have a
question so the question is for the why
would we have to saw put in what we
solve for in the explicit equation and
the answer is absolutely yes that's
exactly the point so this is not a
complete solution to a problem the we
started with an implicit equation we
differentiated and we got in the end
also an implicit equation it doesn't
tell us what Y is as a function of X we
have to go back to this formula to get
the formula for for X so for example
well let me give you an example here so
this is this is the hides a degree of
complexity of the problem but it's a
degree of complexity that we must live
with here so for example at x equals 1
you can see that y equals 1 solves that
happens to be solves y to the 4th plus
XY squared minus 2 is equal to 0 that's
why I picked the 2 actually so it would
be 1 plus 1 minus 2 equals 0 I just
wanted to have a convenient solution
there to pull out of my hat at this
point so I did that and so we now know
that when x equals 1 y equals 1 so at 1
1 along the curve
the slope is equal to what well I have
to plug in here minus 1 squared divided
by 4 times 1 cubed plus 2 times 1 times
1 that's just plugging in that formula
over there which turns out to be minus
1/6 all right so I can get it on the
other hand but at say x equals 2 we're
stuck using this formula star here to
find y okay now so let me let me just
make two points about this which are
just philosophical points for you right
now
the first is when I promised you at the
beginning of this class that we were
going to be able to differentiate any
function you know I meant it very
literally what I meant is if you know
the function we'll be able to give a
formula for the derivative if you don't
know how to find the function you'll
have a lot of trouble finding the
derivative so we didn't make any
promises that if you can't find a
function you will be able to find the
derivative by some magic that will never
happen and however complex the function
is a root of a fourth degree polynomial
is a can be a pretty complicated
function of the coefficients we're stuck
with this degree of complexity in the
problem but the big advantage of this
method notice is that although we've had
to find star we had to find this formula
star or and there are many other ways of
doing these things numerically by the
way which we'll learn later so there's a
good method for doing it numerically
although we had to find start we never
had to differentiate it we had a fast
way of getting the slope so we needed to
know what x and y were but y prime we
got by an algebraic formula
in terms of the values here so this is
very fast for getting the slope once you
know the point yes but what's in the
parentheses sorry you this is well let's
see if I can manage is this this little
is this the parenthesis you're talking
about ah say oh this says say well so
maybe I should put commas around it but
it was s a Y comma comma okay well here
was at at x equals 1 and here's but at
say I'm just throwing out a here any
other value actually there is one value
my favorite value well this is easy to
evaluate right x equals zero I can I can
do it there that's the that's maybe the
only one which is the others are a
nuisance okay all right
other questions okay now now we have to
do something more here so I claimed to
you that that we we could differentiate
all the functions we know but really we
can learn a tremendous about about about
some functions which are really hard to
get out so so this implicit
differentiation method has one very very
important to application to
to finding inverse functions or finding
derivatives of inverse functions so
let's talk about that next
so first maybe we'll just illustrate by
an example if you have the function y is
equal to square root X for X positive
then of course this idea is that we
should simplify this equation and we
should square it so we get this somewhat
simpler equation here and then we have a
notation for this if we call f of X
equal to square root of x and G of Y is
equal to X this is the reversal of the
of this then then the formula for G of Y
is that it should be Y squared and in
general in general if we start with any
old Y is equal to f of X and we just
write down this is the defining relation
for a function G the property that we're
saying is that G of f of X has got to
bring us back to X and we write that in
a couple of different ways we call G the
inverse of F and also we call F the
inverse of G although I'm going to be
silent about which variable I want to
use because people mix them up a little
bit as we'll be doing when we draw a few
pictures of this
so let's let's draw a picture of of both
F and F inverse on the same graph so
first of all first of all I'm going to
draw the graph of f of X is equal to
square root of x all right that's some
shape like this and now in order to
understand what G of Y is so so let's do
the analysis in general but then we'll
draw it in this particular case if you
have G of Y is equal to X that's really
just the same equation right this is the
equation G of Y is equal to X that's y
squared equals x this is y equals square
root of x those are the same equation
it's the same curve but suppose now that
we wanted to write down what G of X is
okay in other words we wanted to switch
the variable so draw them as I said on
the same graph with the same X and the
same y axes then that would be in effect
trading the roles of x and y we have to
rename every point on the graph which is
of the ordered pair X Y and trade it for
the opposite ones and when you exchange
x and y so to do this exchange x and y
and when you do that on the graphically
what that looks like is the following
suppose you have a place here and this
is the X and this is the Y then you want
to trade them so you want the the the Y
here right
and the X up there so it's it's this
sort of opposite place over there and
that is the place which is a directly
opposite this point across the diagonal
line x equals y so you reflect across
this or you flip across that and you get
this other shape that looks like this
maybe I'll draw it with a with a colored
piece of chalk here all right so this
guy here is y equals f inverse of X
right and indeed if you look at these
graphs this one is the square root this
one happens to be y equals x squared
right there just it's if you take this
one and you turn it you reverse the
roles of the x-axis and the y-axis and
tilt it on its side all right so that's
a picture of what an inverse function is
and now I want to show you that the
method of implicit differentiation
allows us to compute the derivatives of
inverse functions so let me just say it
in general and then I'll carry it out
and in particular so implicit
differentiation allows us to find the
derivative of any inverse function
provided we know the derivative of the
function alright so let's do that for
what is an example which is truly
complicated and a little subtle here and
has a very pretty answer so we'll carry
out an example here which is the
function y is equal to the inverse
tangent so again for the inverse tangent
all of the things that we're going to do
are going to be based on simplifying
this equation by taking the tangent of
both sides so let me remind you by the
way the inverse tangent is what's also
known as arctangent of X that's just
another notation for the same thing and
the way we're going to what we're going
to use to describe this function is the
equation tan Y is equal to X that's what
happens when you take the tangent this
function so this is how we're going to
figure out what the function looks like
all right
so first of all I want to draw it and
then and then we'll do the computation
okay so let's let's make the the diagram
first make the sketch so I want to do
something which is analogous to what I
did over here with the square root
function so first of all I remind you
that the tangent function is defined
between two values here which are PI
over two and minus PI over two and it
starts out at minus infinity and curves
up like this
so that's the that's the function tan X
okay and so the one that we have to
sketch is this one which we get by
reflecting this across the axis all
right
so that's going to be well not the axis
sorry the diagonal all right
this slope by the way should be less so
a little lower here so that you can we
can have it going down and up all right
so let me show you what it looks like
so on the front end it's going to look a
lot like this one so this one has curved
down and so the the reflection across
the diagonal curved up here this is
curving up so the reflection is going to
curve down it's going to look like this
all right maybe I should sorry let's use
a different color because it's reversed
from what we had before so I'll just
call it green all right we'll do this
all right now the original curve in the
first quadrant eventually had an
asymptote which was straight up so
this one is going to have an asymptote
which is which is horizontal and that
level is what what's the what's the
highest right there it's as pi over 2 up
here all right now similarly the other
way we're going to do this and this
bottom level is going to be minus PI
over 2 so there's the picture of this
function it's defined for all X so this
green guy is y equals tan inverse X and
it's defined all the way for minus
infinity to infinity and to use a
notation that we we had from limit
notation as X goes to infinity let's say
10 inverse x is equal to PI over 2
that's an example of one value that's of
interest in addition to the finite
values ok so now the first ingredient
that we're going to need is we're going
to need the derivative of a tangent
function so I'm going to recall for you
and you haven't maybe haven't worked
this out yet but I hope that many of you
have that if you take the derivative
with respect to Y of tan Y so this you
do by the quotient rule so you this is
of the form u over V right you use the
quotient rule so I'm going to skip this
ok but what you get in the end is some
marvelous simplification it comes out to
be cosine squared Y here 1 over cosine
squared you can recognize the cosine
squared from the fact that you should
get V squared in the denominator and
somehow the numerator all cancels and
simplifies to 1 ok
and this is also known as secant squared
Y all right
so that's something that if you haven't
done it yet you're going to have to do
this with some exercise all right okay
so we need that ingredient and now we're
just going to differentiate our equation
and what do we get we get again D by dy
tan Y times dy DX is equal to 1 or if
you like 1 over cosine squared Y times
in the other notation Y prime is equal
to 1 so so right so I've used I've just
used the the formula that I just wrote
down there all right now all I have to
do is solve for y prime it's cosine
squared Y ok unfortunately this is not
the form that we ever want to leave
these things in again this is the same
problem we had with that ugly square
root expression or with any of the
others we want to rewrite it in terms of
X our original question was what is d by
DX of tan inverse of X now so far we
have the following answer to that
question it's cosine squared of tan
inverse X ok now this is a a this is a
correct answer
but way too complicated
now that doesn't mean that if you took a
random collection of functions you
wouldn't end up with something that's
complicated but these particular
functions these beautiful circular
functions involved with trigonometry all
have very nice formulas associated with
them and this simplifies tremendously
and so one of the skills that you need
to do to develop when you're dealing
with trig functions is to simplify this
and so let's see now that expressions
like this all simplify so here we go
there's only one formula one ingredient
that we need to use to do this and then
we're going to draw a diagram so the
ingredient again is the original
defining relationship that tan Y is
equal to X so tan y equals x can be
encoded in a right triangle in the
following way here's the right triangle
and tan Y means that Y should be
represented as an angle and then it's
tangent is the ratio of this vertical to
this horizontal side so I'm just going
to pick two values that work namely X
and one those are the simplest ones
so I've encoded this equation in this
picture and now all I have to do is
figure out what the cosine of Y is in
this right triangle here in order to do
that I need to figure out what the
hypotenuse is but that's just square
root of 1 plus x squared and now I can
read off what the cosine of Y is so the
cosine of Y is 1 divided by the
hypotenuse so it's 1 over square root
whoops yeah 1 plus x squared that's ok
and so cosine squared is just 1 over 1
plus x squared and so our answer over
here the preferred
answer which is way simpler than what I
wrote up there is that D by DX of 10
inverse x is equal to 1 over 1 plus x
squared okay now maybe I'll stop here
for one more question I have one more
calculation which I can do even in less
than a minute so we have a whole minute
for questions any questions yeah say
that again what happens to the inverse
tangent the inverse tangent this okay so
this inverse tangent is the same as this
Y here those are the same thing so what
I did was I skipped this step here
kintyre ly I never wrote that down but I
but the inverse tangent was that Y the
issue was what's a good formula for
cosine Y in terms of X so I am
evaluating that but I'm doing it using
the letter Y so in other words what
happened to the inverse tangent is that
I called it Y which is what it's been
all along okay so now I'm going to do
the case of the sine the inverse sine
and I'll show you how easy this is if I
don't fuss with because this one has an
easy trig identity associated with it so
if Y is equal to sine inverse X then
sine Y is equal to X and now watch how
simple it is when I do the
differentiation I just differentiate I
get cosine Y times y prime is equal to 1
all right
and then why prime so that implies that
y prime is equal to one over cosine Y
and now to rewrite that in terms of X I
have to just recognize that this is the
same as this which is the same as 1 over
square root of 1 minus x squared so all
told the derivative with respect to X of
the arcsine function is 1 over square
root of 1 minus x squared right so these
implicit differentiation czar very
convenient however I warn you that you
do have to be careful about the range of
applicability of these things and you
have to draw a picture like this one to
make sure you know where this makes
sense in other words you have to pick a
branch of the sine function to work that
out and there's something like that on
your problem set and it's also discussed
in your text so we'll stop here